well I think that there has been a lot
more cooperation between Afghans at
every level political and military then
probably hits online sometimes show but
i think the real calculation the united
states would make is what are our
strategic interests we have been
episodic lee involved in afghanistan for
the last 50 or 60 years yep i think we
need to figure out what would be the
likely result if there were no American
presence in that region and I think that
those strategic interests need to drive
us now there are moral interest and and
feelings as well but really our ability
to figure out what's best for American
policy should be key well general what
would happen what would be the outcome
in your view if we had no presence in
Afghanistan what I found when I entered
afghanistan as the commander in 2009 was
the biggest shortcoming in afghanistan
was confidence it was confidence on the
part of the Afghan people confidence in
the part of their government and
confidence in the different members of
the coalition I think that that
confidence has increased and I know the
capability has increased I'm actually
optimistic that there is a great
opportunity to establish a stable
Afghanistan right now I do think that
the Afghans need the sense of a reliable
partner the United States and other
Western nations so I think that that
confidence must be buttressed by the
idea that we are there for them right
and we know that the reason why general
that the relationship between
Afghanistan at least between the
president of Kanna Stan and president
brocco Obama has gone south is partly
because of the u.s. beginning these
peace talks with the Taliban in Qatar
and given that development and how they
feel about it should we continue those
talks should we begin those talks well I
think it's necessary to go into
negotiations with the Taliban but I
think we need to remember that this is
Afghanistan's future that we're talking
about so the government of Afghanistan
led by President Karzai have to be major
players in the outcome because they're
going to live with it and I think it's
important that we not in any way
diminish the importance of their role
general let me switch over to what's
going on in Egypt oh you know we
obviously in the United States we we
provide Egypt aid much of that goes
towards the military in Egypt do you
support what happened there well I
support the idea that Egypt is moving to
a democracy now that road is going to
have a lot of twists and turns and it's
not certainly not going as straight as
some people might like it to be I think
that what we need to do is help Egypt
take a long-term view at how they are
going to get a truly pluralistic
government that represents all the
different interests not just one or the
other right i think that it's also
necessarily we all remember that egypt
has tremendous economic problems right
now so under the surface of all the
political upheaval that you see or some
economic realities that are going to
face any regime and I think we need to
be prepared to help Egypt or I think
that could be a propellant for more
problems so we should not pull Aid I
think that our relationship with Egypt
is very very important I think we need
to remain a partner with Egypt ok but
what happened there though and I'm sure
you must know the military leadership
there in Egypt was it a military coup
there well I certainly wouldn't
characterize it one way or another I
think what happened was there was a
vision by part of the group that had
overthrown President Mubarak the more
secular group I think they came to the
conclusion that President Morsi and his
regime was going in a direction that
they were uncomfortable with and they
decided to act the military's role you
could argue came in to stop that
violence I don't want to go further in
their political decision because they
really haven't come out and said one way
or another how familiar are you with the
leadership there I'm sorry how familiar
are you with the generals the
rolls in Egypt I've met some of them not
familiar with their thinking now I
certainly wouldn't claim to know their
current calculations all right general I
want to just quickly turn to what you're
working on here in the United States I
know the Franklin project is something
that has come out of the Aspen
leadership is the Aspen Institute
basically you're encouraging American
young Americans to go into public
service you've had what something like
over 500,000 applicants for like 80
2,000 jobs or something of that of that
nature why are you seeing such a big
response what are you seeing here well
we've got a bipartisan group of people
who are pushing for the idea of
universal national service which would
be voluntary but expected for young
people as they leave high school or
college and the idea is that they would
do a year of full-time work be paid a
living stipend but the real objective
here is to increase our ability to give
opportunities to people from all across
America not just people of means who can
afford to support themselves while they
do volunteer work but the the real goal
here is to work in healthcare education
conservation also the military and to
view in people a sense of renewed
linkage to their country a sense of
renewed responsibility for the nation
and a responsibility to each other and
how do you make sure though that it's
all Americans at participate this and
not just those who are on the wealthier
side of the scale that's a great
question really you have got to provide
opportunities with funding because if if
someone doesn't have the opportunity to
to support themselves you've got to have
enough funding so that we can give them
full time opportunities for the period
of service and that could allow us also
to mix our young people people from East
LA could be working with people from
scarsdale in teams and I think that that
would help bridge gaps that that are
very important in America
right now